[موسيقى]
الذكرى الخامسه والثمانون لعيد الشهداء
مناسبه يخلد فيها التونسيون محطه حاسمه من
تاريخهم في المواجهه مع الاحتلال الفرنسي
ففي التاسع من ابريل عام
تظهرت تونسيون في الشارع للمطالبه بحكومه
وطنيه وبرلمان تونسي هي ذاتها الاهداف
التي يسعى الرئيس قيس سعيد الى تحقيقها
كما يقول كانوا عزا يطالبون ببرلمان تونسي
وطالبوا ببرلمانا انسي وابشا الله
البرلمان الذي حلم به التونسيون في تلك
الفتره هو الذي سيحقق اراده الشعب التونسي
اليوم وغدا
المعارضه التونسيه ممثله بجبهه الخلاص
الوطني احيت بدورها ذكرى عيد الشهداء في
شارع الحبيب بورقيبه وقال رئيسها ان
الثوره ستنتصر على الانقلاب الغاشم على حد
وصفه ما نعيشه اليوم مجرد قوس سيغلق سيبلغ
في القريب العاجل ليست جبهه التي تقوله
هذا وقد قالته منذ اشهر وانما العالم
باسره اليوم يقول بان تونس تهدد بالانهيار
الوسيم ويستعد الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل مع عدد من المنظمات المدنيه الفاعله
الى اطلاق مبادره للحوار الوطني مره اخرى
المعارضه التونسيه الى تكثيف وجودها في
الشارع بينما يمضي الرئيس قيس سعيد قدما
في المسار الذي يعتبره التصحيحا الانحراف
من كانوا في السلطه دون اي افق لوساطه او
حوار وطني ينهي الازمه في البلاد سيف
الدين الجزيره تونس